I've never wanted to get married and
it's never that's never been something
that's important to me but you want a
great love of your life you want I to
amazing little great loves of my life
right now my life is filled with love
Charlie I'm not talking about the kids
Charlie's look at me
yes we're talking about romance this is
a big thing yes she the love of your
children is great I just had a great
Father's Day with my girls it was
fantastic don't get me wrong
yeah but you get lonely and I mean
Nigella
I have never been lonely Wow are you
scared of romantic love in a sense no
not at all I'm just my life right now
just doesn't allow for a lot of room for
something like that to happen something
that's already incredibly difficult to
achieve when you're not a single mom
with a career I enjoy being set up on
dates I don't know if I'll ever be able
to live with somebody again to be
totally Frank they might have to buy the
house next to me cuz I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to like [ __ ] deal with
that ever again like I'm too old for
that [ __ ] our men disgusting in the
sense that I find them gross I mean
maybe that's what it is like you told
Jimmy Kimmel a story which I was
fascinated by like you went out on a
date and some guy was you know
good-looking guy he turns to you at the
end the night and you give him a kiss
and he says hey make out with my nose
what even does that mean that is a lot
of people are into I just I what
yeah yeah take a look at my nose like
ways we put the tongue up what does that
mean put the tongue up my nostril